all right um another supplemental video
to kiteen nogin as a Keyon 101
video what we have to
understand is that spiraling
cross again okay and I'm going to
demonstrate it by several means here
okay and it is going to require
that UK has to learn to rule differently
than the Contemporary UK rules
today um because we are not doing an
acceleration
throw um we're
doing the same thing we always do with
this cross which is to
deconstruct UK's ability to remain
upright so that gravity can work upon
him
and then that way we are throwing UK UK
doesn't decide
to um undo their own base of support
their own equilibrium Etc we are
deconstructing the elements necessary
for them to remain upright and hence we
are throwing them okay as I've discussed
with uh some
people
um even though most today feel like
they've been
thrown uh they they haven't been because
they've never had this base of
support entirely
deconstructed and so they always have
some sense of
control uh that they maintain as they're
in air quotes here being thrown so when
you first try this with your
UK uh you're going to freak the hell out
of them because it's Pro is the first
time they've actually been thrown
okay there is a spiritual reason for why
we deconstruct this space of support so
of course obviously there's an easy to
see tactical
reason um but there is a spiritual
reason in
that UK we have now brought
fear and it's self attachment it's
manifestation of self-attachment into
the training and so de constructing UK's
base is the Catalyst for reconciling
fear because fear has been brought in
because all control has been taken away
control the need for control the
Reliance for control all that is
fear but there's also in the way that we
deconstruct the base we deconstruct the
base through that spiraling rotating
cross and as we've already said multiple
times this is an easy way to understand
and a Reconciliation between yin and
yangong and thereby a return to the DA
that that is the energetic component
today we're going to take
off the spiritual aspect but just be
aware of it when you throw your UK like
this for the first time they're going to
freak
out uh they're not going to like
it and then we're going to take off the
energetic aspect as well uh so that we
just understand it physically
okay if you
have um in simple terms let's say this
is the head of
UK and they're going to be taken into
that front inward kazushi which I'll
demonstrate again for those that haven't
heard me use that
term what we're going to do everything
happens on a spiral everything is
rotating is this lever here is UK's
spine and we're going to take the top
part of that
spine and make it go this
way and we're going to take the bottom
half of that spine and make it go this
way okay everyone goes okay cool spiral
circle but the way that we're going to
do this is with that x pattern that we
we've demonstrated all the
time we're going to do a CQ
projection right through UK
tanden okay and that's going to be your
yang
line and your CQ
line and here at the head this is your
Yin
line and there a accomplished through an
ity
adhesion
okay when we do this you're going to
imagine somewhere if you will UK's
planted foot we're only going to give
him
one is somewhere I don't know somewhere
in this region okay and it's not too far
outside of the spine so if nag is over
here the foot is somewhere around here
okay
so let's return to basic angle of
disturbance Concepts okay so we have to
know the line of
gravity we have to know the center of
gravity and we have to know the base of
support at a
minimum
and this line of gravity is a
theoretical line drawn from the center
gravity perpendicular to in this case
the
Earth and as long as that line of
gravity is inside the Bas of
support UK will have balance we'll have
it's it's going to be a dynamic
equilibrium but it's equilibrium
nonetheless and I would put before you
the there is no equilibrium that is not
a dynamic equilibrium for human beings
okay basis support is that foot only in
this case Okay so if that line of
gravity is over that foot UK is going to
have a sense of control and they can
decide how they want to roll when they
want to roll ultimately okay what we're
going to do instead is we're going to
send uh this thing one way
and this thing another way so that the
line of gravity is going to be outside
the base of
support and the base of support can
never be put back underneath that line
of gravity that is what I mean by
deconstructing balance here
okay I'll show you what that what that
looks like now spec with specifics okay
okay so if we look at
yesterday we in those variations of
kiten n uh UK was in that three-point
stance so go ahead and go back into that
three-point
stance okay and you can put your hand on
the ground cuz you would have that
available okay and so his base of
support let me identify it it's going to
be this
hand this
foot that foot and then all the AR area
shaded
in and then you'd find his center of
gravity it's probably somewhere around
here in the middle of his body and then
the line of gravity would
travel theoretically down through that
Center
gravity and you would find I'll I'll
I'll kind of superimpose
this but it's here that it's inside his
basis support and hence remains balanced
okay to show you how this is working and
staying with last night's
information if I was I guess you're
roing this
side showing the OT
mechanics when I take this
arm this
way that line of gravity will move up
his body as the center of gravity it
moves up his body as you start to lower
the head do you see can you guys see
that so that line of gravity that was
here as I start to move it starts to
come forward and eventually it's going
to fall outside that hand and that's
what takes his
balance you come
back and staying with yesterday's
example
again moving his
hand this way in yesterday's example we
went it this
way would have to take that center of
gravity and that's the line of gravity
outside of that foot in order for him to
fall and you can
see no it's not going to work okay but
this does this doesn't take any effort
here I'll give you another example at
the theoretical level he's
down Center gravity somewhere around
here line of ravity is
somewhere straight down around here it's
inside as basic
support if I pushing backwards that L
that center of gravity is going towards
his tailbone and eventually the line of
gravity will end up outside of the Bas
of support and he will fall and again
we're just looking at it conceptually I
don't want to introduce new material
right now so everything is static okay
all
right in the throw you saw in my kiten
net
videos due to the inertial patterns that
we end up using we never put the guy in
a three-point stance okay so he has one
leg on the ground you see he's going to
be somewhere like this okay and if you
don't mind come here so he can balance
off you you go
okay and so the same thing the Bas of
support is this foot because he's going
to be flying that hand's not going to be
on the mat cuz he's in an inertial
spiral so the basic support in this case
is just the foot as you see him kind of
tilted this way the center of gravity is
somewhere around here you draw that line
of gravity it's over the foot and you
can hang out here so you can let go and
use your balance as long as it keeps his
Center gravity over his foot the line of
gravity in his base of support and he
has balance okay come
back so we have to apply the same rules
so he's going to go back there you can
use me for balance now just so you can
talk what I'm going to do with that CQ
line the Yong line is take that center
of
gravity and move it further to his right
in fact with a CQ projection I'm going
to move it so far
past his outer edge of this Bas of
support that he has to fall because it's
going to be that line of gravity is
outside his Bas of support so I will not
do a CQ projection here I'll just do a
force vector and you can see what
happens to
him when we add
our
adhesion and we're moving his head this
way
that's going to
accentuate that Co projection and the
displacement of this line of gravity
outside so I'll just do a force Vector
pulling in and a force
Vector pushing out and this happens much
sooner when you do the CQ projection so
these were just mechanical
representations of the force lines when
you you do a CQ projection his Center
boom goes completely outside of that leg
and it's more something like
this and now that I projected his Center
outside of that Bas of support usually
it's about 6 in to anywhere up to 2 feet
if I feel like it if anyone feels like
it okay there's no way he can get that
foot back underneath that line of
gravity and this is what guarantees that
I'm throwing him and he doesn't get a
choice his only choice again is how does
he land that's his only choice okay back
to that spiritual
component and you don't even know how to
do this so you're going to have to
listen to me okay you're going to have
to roll like the iy1 kids where they
kind of do a somersault going straight
ahead and in that direction yeah can I
can I see if you can even do that just
do a roll Straight Ahead okay there we
go
so in our Dojo that's incorrect because
he'll he'll never be able to roll that
way okay that makes sense if I
accelerate them that way then that rule
makes perfect
sense but that's not what I'm
doing okay so you're going to try to do
that got it and give them some room
there I don't know where you want to be
okay but I'm going to push and pull and
you're going to try try to do your
forward
roll it's impossible okay you see that
okay you're not going to be able to do
that
okay and we we'll demonstrate it again
um let's uh let's see if you could get
your foot under under under back
underneath you so I'm going to send you
that way use all your ath athleticism to
just get your base back underneath you
okay good and now this is why you have
to do both so when I hold his head and
and I and I push
here much harder for him to do okay and
then as you're able to project that line
of Gravity by projecting his Hut up
completely out there it becomes pretty
much impossible for most I'm sure
there's a person out there that could do
it but it becomes pretty impossible so
you're going to do that same thing where
you get cool and you're
here can't do it okay and that's what
we're trying to achieve
okay all right we'll take that into a
key
uh one thing I never do is for example
in the uh common ones is UK I don't know
it's supposed to be going that way but
usually people stop right so there's no
spinal displacement but at some point
and if I was able to do this and we saw
last night I'm not able to do this so UK
goes with
me well energy is now going that way so
now I'm going against the energy Okay so
I don't do that version
anymore as some of you know from my
lineage cha Sensei did do that that
version but it doesn't make sense
energetically nor martially either
okay so I want you to look at something
that showed up yesterday when you pin
that
foot we show that he could not step on
that foot that foot gets
planted but do due to the inertia that
keep kept going the other leg stepped
through so that's what we're going to do
here eventually he he's going to reach
to grab to start over like you I'm there
he's going to reach to grab
okay slower and when he reaches to grab
I lower that and I let that foot come
through I don't want to wait here you
could if you wanted I guess but it's not
the way way to do the
technique and start over I don't want to
be ahead of
him I have to have the timing so this
thing will
drop and I have to move in way that I
clear the line with your intention and
this thing goes this
way and that hand is going to give you
your CQ
hand
I'll do it
again because there's nothing acting on
the head he should not do a roll but you
can see the
line clear
boom
hop if you pay
attention even in Su waza you use this
all the time so let's say I'm doing EO I
move him around his shoulder passes me
and then the inward spiral will come
in boom
boom only thing I'm doing different here
is I don't do the inverse spiral one
C let his shoulder past
you
reject
reject let's have you guys try this see
what wasn't all right so um stand by
okay so you're are you're at where
you're at and there's nothing wrong that
you're in the right place to stop being
where you're at okay but I I want to
demonstrate uh that spiritual aspect
okay because now they're falling into
the boy on the first yield and then the
I adhesion is making them have to fall
into the void okay so you have an
inertial resistance to him getting off
of that Vector because it was generated
per prescription okay but once he's off
on it there's an inertial resistance
it's hard for him to go backwards it's
hard for him to pull out and then
there's an i adhesion inside the grip
that also adds resistance towards him
getting off of that inertial resistance
and that's the first sign uh or or the
first experience he has and he's not in
control something else someone else is
in control and fear comes in as he's
used to seeking control okay it's a fear
response so we'll watch the the two UK
it usually shows up in a a kind of
seasoning in here and trying to stop
what's happening okay it shows up in the
center so we have two different levels
of UK and we'll start with Tristan and
he Tristan is zuk and he is experienced
in accepting the void okay which is no
self no control no need for control
and you can see his body he
goes and we'll just keep
going did you see did you did you see
the the seasoning that
Happ okay and we're going to increase
that void by making the ukas per
prescription come in faster and we'll
see an elevated resistance towards it so
go okay you can see it okay all
right
okay all right so uh my friend Ivan
that's what that's what you were
experiencing it's very very common okay
that that UK aren't used to it because
most of our Lives we live in fear and we
always seeking control over our
environment
okay all right so uh this we actually
uh that was in the kids class where we
filmed earlier then we did body
conditioning now we're in the adult
class and I don't remember where we left
off so we'll try to I know it was
somewhere around here in this part here
okay I think yeah okay um so if you pay
attention where I move how I move is
going to be very much like when we were
going over the conceptual breakdown I'm
kind of in this area this is where I was
able to pull the neck and this is where
I was able to project the hip so you
can't just be anywhere and no conceptual
understanding of how to deconstruct a
basis support is going to put you in the
right place that's a my problem okay my
so you have to learn
uh how to do
that
[Music]
okay let's try so common
mistakes common mistakes are that I I
wait to get the head and he's going to
come up
already so this hand W should go right
onto the head as early as possible and
then the two start
working the relationship to tilt him
okay another common mistake is uh you
feel oh his weight you feel his weight
and so the co hand follows the head this
way you see so you're kind of doing like
a somersault this
way no you want the x pattern and
likewise you feel the wing here so you
push this
hand you going to stand
up so
[Music]
remember this comes this way back this
way towards
me don't use it the two to push
[Music]
boom
all right let's try it okay so your iy
hand is going to go in and
down this
way because it's a yinyang
world your coku hand is going to go out
and
up it's this way C II this way don't do
both they they do different things you
want a spiraling rotating cross so boom
boom on that up
hand
next
next thing different UK do different
things different things so he might
feel oh I'm being
moved and he'll let go get your hand off
of there there you
go so you were vectoring into the center
it's this this way
so when he lets go this hand goes here
now it does the same
thing W he lets go just goes
here okay did you getat it no it's
didn't all right d I think got to come
on I don't know figure out the angle
you're the
photographer so one he let's go it's
right there I'm
the he doesn't like go
though he did Don't Let Go like a good
can so that I can continue to trade my
cou projection could won't let go but
scar do go to the
HP
again there's that
my that you have to solve for where you
would be in a
place granting all the
inertia where I can make this head go
around
me and I can make this line of gravity
go on the a I got to be in that right
place
okay so and usually again and even here
right we're too far out and the heads
can't go around me now we're trying to
do the throws
okay no matter what variation you're
going to work solto Uchi K you have to
end up in that same place for the UR
okay so I I might do this version and I
got to get right there again there's the
spot can go around me I can project that
way I
DOI I got to end up in that spot again
head can go around me move where you are
head can go around me we're just going
to do
it boom I move
myself in that same spot head can go
around me Center can go across the
headline um it doesn't matter if it's
ski I got to do this same next there it
is again back one
step he's coming
forward same exact thing I just end up
there no matter what variation you're
doing on the
UR if you make a
mistake and you're too far in front of
it and over here this head's not going
to go around me that's where that that
mul comes in there's room for it now
you're too far ahead of it so even if
you do this
one it's not going to go around me and
that's where
the OT come in okay you just have to do
it while he's moving not planted like
that all right so I'll let you play with
u what animal any variation get yourself
in the right mind